What is Git, and what's it used for?
What's thedifference between Git and GitHub, or GitLab?
I'm Nathan Hekman from IBM Cloud and
I'm going to answer that for you today,
but before I do, please hit that "Subscribe" button.
Now let's "git" started with an example.
Let's say you work for a media streaming company
and you'retasked with building a music player app.
So, you want to be able to be able to play musicof all sorts of genres on a device
and you're tasked with developing this application with a
team of developers, right - it's not just you.
How do you work with that team of developers
andwrite code at the same time as them
on the same code base or project without conflicting?
Well, that's where Git and GitHub, or GitLab, come in.
So, what is Git, right?
So, Git is what's known asa version control system.
That might not mean a whole lot to you right now, but we'll jump intowhat exactly that means.
How about GitHub?
Or GitLab?
Well, GitHub or GitLab are actually hosted ... Git.
So, where Git is actually the underlying
system that runs on your local machine,
GitHub or GitLab is hosted maybe in the cloud,
or hosted via the web,
to host that Git system, as well as add a few more useful features.
Youmay know GitHub or GitLab as a very diverse community, open source community,
where developersfrom all over the world can work together and collaborate on different code or projects.
So, let's talk about some of the benefits and and aspects
of Git and GitHub andhow they work together.
So, first of all, it allows you to track your changes.
So, youalways have a state tracking exactly what changes were made at any time.
Kind of goingalong with that, it's a historical backupusing ...
... basically you canthink of them as snapshots,right?
So, it's it's kind of like a "Save as"button.
So, you're probably familiar withthat.
You basically can keep a previous version and revert to it if you need to
while still copying and then making changes on top of thatprevious version.
So, if you introduce a bug or mess something up
you can always go backwith a historical backup that it provides
and revert those changes.
What else?
So, maybeone of the biggest benefits that Git and GitHub allow
are just team-based development.
So, like we were talking about over here,
it allows a team of developers to actuallywork on the same code simultaneously
and then merge their changes in together tomake progress on a project.
Pretty cool.
Next, it's also very flexible,
so itallows you to work locally on a project
or Git or GitHub can be used as part of yourDevOps flows
so that you can integrate your repository, which we'll talk about in a second,
and your project and actually have it be part of an automated test,
so kick off automatedtesting, or be part of your automated buildand deploy processes.
So, that's a reallyneat aspect, it's very flexible.
And then finally, so, Git is typically ... you interact with it usingthe command line on your local machine
versus GitHub is on the web, right - it's a website, andthat's how you interact with GitHub or GitLab.
And, finally, a concept that I think is important to
understand
about Git and GitHub, or GitLab, is that it's trunk-based development.
So, whatdoes that mean? Think of a trunk like a tree, right?
So, you have this main ... you can think ofmain code,
and you as a developer maybe will want to branch off of that main branch ofcode,
make some changes and then merge your code back into that main branch.
And, over here, youmight have another developer that branches offof the main branch,
makes some changes, and thenmerges back into that main branch.
That's trunk-based development.
All right, let's dive intoour example and see what exactly this looks like.
So, let's say that you have what'scalled a repository.
So, repository.
What's a repository?
It's a place tostore your code and your changes to code,
and in this case it's going to be hostedon the cloud or in the web on GitHubor GitLab.
And, at the sametime, let's say over here that Iam working.
I want to work on this this code baseon my local machine, right.
So, how do I do that?
Well, I need to do what's called "clone"this repo onto my local machine and I create,
... remember our trunk based development?
I createa branch of code called "Nathan-branch".
So, that's where I'm going to be making my
changes to the code base.
And let's say ... well, what changes do I want to make?
Well, I'ma huge Bluegrass fan, OK?
So, I want to make the home page of the application feature Bluegrass.
So, down here, let's say that I have my application
and we call this our working copy.
So, thisis where I'm going to actually be making changes
to that working copy to feature Bluegrass musicon the application homepage.
Great!
So, once I'm happy with those changes what I'm going to dois I'm going to actually commit them,
say "commit",
those changes to Nathan-branch,
and then, once I'm happy there, everything's committed,
I'm going to go ahead and pushthose changes
back over to our cloud-hosted repo in GitHub.
So, I'm goingto go ahead and push those changes.
Perfect!
Happy with that, right? Let's make it a littlemore complicated.
So, over here my co-worker, Greg,
is also wanting to make some changes to the application home screen,
and now he happens to be making these changes beforeI pushed up my Bluegrass changes back to the ...
... we'll call this the main-branch.
So, he doesn't have my changes yet, so when he clones down to his local machine
he wants to makesome changes, he has a little different style preference for music.
He's a huge Rock fan,OK?
And so, over here on his working copy,
he's going to make the home screen featureRock music.
And so when he goes aheadand he makes those changes
and then hecommits them back to what we call "Greg-branch",
he's happy with those changes, hewants to go ahead and merge those
and push them back to the main-branch.
So, let's see, what does he need to do in order
to do that?
Well, he'll actually need to pull and merge whatever is in the main-branch,
because at this point as he's been working I'vealready pushed up my Bluegrass changes.
So, nowhe has to pull those down into his Greg-branch and merge them.
Uh-oh. Guess what?
There is what'scalled a "merge conflict", that happens right here, right?
So, when he's pulling down those changeshe's been modifying the same code.
So, there's a conflict that he needs to resolve there.
So,what does he do?
Like any good co-worker he compromises, right?
So, he makes the main screenof the app feature both Bluegrass and Rock.
So, he makes those changes in his branch,
and he's readyto actually get those back in the main-branch.
So, the next step he needs to take is:
he needs to submit what's called a "pullrequest".
You may have heard folks talk abouta "P.R.", right? That's what a pull request is.
What is it? It's basically
a way for him to say,"Hey, these are the changes that I want to make",
and it can be viewed in GitHub or GitLab
so thatanyone on the development team, like Nathan,
I can go ahead and look at those changes and Isay, "Good job Greg, looks great!"
And I can approve the pull request and then get those changesmerged into the main-branch.
So, you'll see the final version of the application looks awesome,
Bluegrass and Rock both featured on the main page. Awesome!
So, hopefully this makesit clear about what exactly Git is,
how is it related to GitHub and GitLab,
and how they are fundamental to developing applications not only by yourself,
butas a team of developers.
Thank you.
If you have questions please drop us a linebelow.
If you want to see more videos like this in the future, please like and subscribe.
And don't forget,
you can grow your skills and earn a badge with IBM CloudLabs
which are free,browser-based interactive Kubernetes labs.